nous en venons à votre actualité
christian lacroix les défilés prêt à
porter pour l'automne et l'hiver
prochain se succèdent jusqu'à demain à
paris votre défilé à vous avait lieu
hier en fin de journée l'occasion pour
nous de mieux vous connaître
il faut dire que votre créativité ne
s'arrête pas au podium on vous sollicite
dans les domaines les plus divers les
plus inattendus il ya un esprit lacroix
en dehors de tout mode un univers
métissé sabine gorny olivier palomino
dix neuf ans qu'il raconte avec passion
la même belle histoire celle d'une femme
du sud
altière et cher à la recherche éternelle
de sa belle arlésienne la croix c'est
celui qui ont soleil la mode parisienne
celui qui suscite à chaque collection un
délicieux frissons et l'émotion pure
c'est les larmes aux yeux c'est les
premières le premier passage c'est les
larmes aux yeux que ce succès la poésie
c'est l'émotion son coeur déborde dans
tout ce qu'il fait et c'est ça qui est
formidable et c'est vrai qu on les aime
né en arles celui-ci du taureau ça ne
s'invente pas en 87
il fait son entrée dans l'arène de la
haute couture par la voie royale celle
d'une maison à son nom financé par
bernard arnault la provence s'est plaint
voyance
le monde entier est sous le charme le
mariage avec lvmh durera 18 ans trop
partie phrase assez rentable ni
commercial l'an dernier il est remercié
rachetée par un groupe américain
une nouvelle page de sa vie ce qui
s'écrit on n'arrivait pas à transformer
cette maison en une réalité commerciale
ou était très patient j'ai attendu face
une vingtaine d'années pour tirer cette
conclusion je crois que c'est un peu
comme certains mariages d'amour
il vaut mieux un bon divorce pour
repartir plus peut-être plus frais
punaises dans une autre vie il aurait
aimé être au cos culié toujours cette
nostalgie du rideau rouge
il a signé les costumes de bérénice
phèdre cosi fan tutte l'opéra garnier
le met a new york les arènes de nîmes
ont été ses plus beaux podiums
on aime christian lacroix parce que
c'est quelqu'un qui reste est totalement
libre dans son travail qui a jamais été
muselés par des contraintes marketing et
pourtant les marques se l'arrachent
il a relooké les cinémas gaumont ni des
couleurs dans le tgv
il a même rhabiller le personnel d'air
france n'en parle constamment depuis
quelques mois dans les avions on est
tous très impatients de pouvoir le
porter très prochainement et enluminé le
dictionnaire
car des défilés de mode au mode de vie
il n'ya qu'un fils avec le temps ils
m'ont pourtant à cet humaniste passionné
et pour monter une seule chose un peu de
légèreté